Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen. Morgen.
Sitzt noch gar nicht so lange her, dass wir die letzte Sendung gemacht haben, wa?
Nee, wir äh ist noch nicht so lange her, ne.
Nicht so lange her.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik, die einundfünfzigste Ausgabe in schneller Folge.
Schneller. Ist einundfünfzig eine besondere Zahl. Nee, nee. Die irgendwo hat die irgendwas besonders.
Bestimmt. Ich meine, im Internet findest du ja auch immer die passende Verschwörungstheorie dazu, ne. Grade bei solchen noch etwas unter äh gedeuteten Zahlen. Das sind ja sozusagen die Newcomer.
Berlin einundfünfzig Reinickendorf für die Ecke.
Berlin haben nur zwei zahlende Bedeutungen.
Und Paragraph einundfünfzig Urheberrechtsgesetz, Zitate.
Ja, das ist schon, also Bedeutung.
Weiter, Bogen, ja, ja, das geradezu aufgeladen. Das äh ja, dann berichten wir halt jetzt von den äh Aliens hier,
Was haben wir denn so vor den, von den Aliens?
Von den Aliens. Wir haben eine ähm,
Man könnte ja sagen, so äh die Leute, die mal von Aliens reden, die reden ja immer von Gefahren, von denen viele andere sagen, dass sie nicht da sind, ja, also kein äh niemand hat vor, dich als Alien zu entführen oder so,
und ähm ähnlich war's ja immer mit den,
äh Avocado der Netznetralität, die vor vielen Dingen gewarnt haben so auch ich ja einmal in der längeren Sendung zur Netzneutralität, die als äh Einführung der Hörerinnen an dieser Stelle nochmal im,
Fohlen sein sollte.
Meinst deinen Auftritt bei den Datenspuren?
Unseren Auftritt bei den Datenspuren.
Unseren. Na ja, ich habe ja nur Steigbügelhalter. Ich bin ja hier sowieso nur der Steigbügelhalter.
Ich meine, meckert der hier halt. Ähm.
Muss mich mal meckern sehen. Ist mal ein anderes Programm umschalten.
Stimmt, ich bin froh, dass ich keine Kalenderapps für iOS entwickel,
Also äh was ist was ist passiert? Ähm es gibt ein ein wieder ein neue, ein eine neue Schreckensnachricht von äh von der Netzneutralität. Die verletzt wird.
Oh Gott.
Problemen, die entstehen. Und zwar stellte sich der,
Stefan Richard, der CEO des äh Internetproviders Orange,
Er stellte sich in einem TV-Interview hin und ähm berichtete stolz, dass er in der, dass er Geld von äh Google bekommt, für Traffic.
In welchem Land?
Orange ist ursprünglich France Telekom, aber äh den gehören natürlich, wie das so ist in sehr vielen Ländern ähm,
Internetanbieterangebote. Ich hab.
Ja, aber nicht in den USA, sondern Orange ist ja im Wesentlichen.
Nee, das ist ein Franzose, es ist ein äh Franzose vermutlich.
Ja, aber ich meine, gilt das jetzt sozusagen nur für Frankreich oder gilt das generell für alle Netze von äh Orange.
Ging da jetzt nicht so äh draus hervor. Ich würde jetzt mal fast sagen, also er hat ich suche gerade die Zahl. Er hat nämlich seit die Anzahl seiner Nutzer genannt. Äh für die er äh für die er quasi spricht,
und ähm damit angegeben sagte, man muss natürlich auch erstmal so viele Nutzer haben
um Google auf Augenhöhe begegnen zu können. Insofern würde ich vermuten, dass er das äh sogar international meint, aber in dem Bericht äh in dem englischen Bericht darüber sagt er
ähm dass,
Insbesondere die Dominanz von Orange in Afrika, der äh der Hebel war äh ähm mit Google ein finanzielles Arrangement zu finden,
was die Bezahlung des Traffics angeht, den Orange von Google an seine äh Nutzer bewegt.
Gibt's da konkretere Zahlen, was äh diese Dominanz in Afrika betrifft?
Nein, äh ach so, die Dominanz von Orange in Afrika, weiß ich nicht, aber vermutlich ist sie einfach groß. Also in Afrika werden.
Dominanz von Orange oder die Dominanz von Google.
Von Orange, also im Prinzip beides, ja, also er sagt, wir, also in in Afrika, in vielen Ländern, äh ich habe da ja mal vor,
Wann war das denn? Zweitausendneun habe ich da mal drüber berichtet, wie das in äh Leso war im kleinen äh kleiner Enklave in in Südafrika. Da bauen die tatsächlich ja jetzt so insbesondere Mobilfunknetze erst hin, die,
überspringen in einigen Ländern sogar das äh im Prinzip diese gesamte Festnetzentwicklung, weil sie das noch nicht mal haben und es im Prinzip einfacher ist, ein äh ein Mobilfunknetz zu bauen als ein als ein Festnetz, ja?
Das ist in Afrika generell so, weil da kannst du gar kein Festnetz liegen, weil also du kannst es liegen, aber es ist halt zehn Minuten später dann auch später ausgegraben. Na ja.
Genau, das ist halt, ja. So, ähm,
Jetzt geht ihr also hin und sagt, okay, wir wir sind ein großer äh ein großer Provider oder eine Firmengruppe, der unendlich viele Provider auch Anteile daran gehören, also in Großbritannien und äh Frankreich,
Ähm,
sind so die größten Bastionen von Orange. Dann haben sie in Spanien, haben sie äh gehört ihnen neunundneunzig Prozent von dem spanischen Anbieter Orange, Tunesien, neunundvierzig Prozent Uganda, dreiundfünfzig Prozent ähm
Und da gibt's also überall diesen Anbieter äh Orange äh Rumänien,
haben sie große Anteile Lichtenstein ja also die.
Jetzt nicht zu Afrika.
Nein, das genau. Äh äh Elfenbeinküste zieht da zum Beispiel und dem äh zu.
Botswarner haben sie auch noch.
Eine lange Liste ist da verlinkt. Es geht darum oder der entscheidende Punkt ist, sie sind ein sehr großer Provider, er gibt der CEO, stellt sich hin, gibt damit an, dass sie Geld von Google bekommen.
Und sagt klar, das sind jetzt nicht hunderte von Millionen, aber wir kriegen von Google Geld für deren Traffic. So, warum?
Warum kriegen sie dafür Geld? Er sagt, dass es in vielen Ländern so wäre, dass bis zu fünfzig Prozent des Traffics, den die Nutzer bei Orange,
oder anfordern, den also Orange seinen Nutzern ausliefert, von Google kommt. Insbesondere natürlich über den, über YouTube, was auch Google gehört.
Und damit begründet äh äh Steve Stephan Richard, dass äh er von Google Geld äh
das sind das ist seinem Unternehmen zustünde von Google Geld zu bekommen, welches dann selbstverständlich für den Netzausbau genutzt wird,
nicht etwa äh als Gewinn irgendwo verbucht wird in diesem Unternehmen,
Selbstverständlich. So, warum ist das jetzt ein, warum ist das ein Problem? Wir hatten das ja ähm.
Verstehe das auch Google überhaupt nicht, warum die sich auf sowas überhaupt einlassen.
Die Frage ist tatsächlich, also die die Argumentation von Google an der Stelle müsste ja sein,
Das ja interessant Orange, dass äh deine Nutzer fünfzig Prozent dein, der Nutzung, also die haben einen Orange-Vertrag offensichtlich, um unsere Dienste zu nutzen.
Ja. Das heißt, die Google Dienste sind der Grund, warum sie dort Kunde werden und deswegen zahlen sie da Geld.
Da hätte Google, müsste eigentlich zu Orange gehen und sagen, Freunde, euer gesamtes Geschäftsmodell scheint doch nicht zu funktionieren, wenn wir äh YouTube ausschalten für euch.
Und dann sagen die wahrscheinlich, na ja, also so viel Daten da abgerufen werden und so wenig äh Leute in Afrika dafür bezahlen können. Das lohnt sich irgendwie alles gar nicht äh und da jetzt den Netzausbau, das rentiert sich nicht und ich würde noch nicht mal ausschließen, dass es so ist,
Was ich mich nur frage ist, wenn ich Google wäre, ja,
würde ich da einfach so irgendwas bezahlen? Oder würde ich nicht eigentlich lieber losgehen und mir einfach Anteile an diesen scheiß Laden holen und sagen, okay, hier,
investieren jetzt hier auch mal in den Laden, sind dann aber auch daran beteiligt, dürfen da auch mitreden und äh äh tragen hier auch ähm zum Netzausbau bei.
Ich vermute, dass es bestimmte äh,
einmal taktische Erwägungen bei Google gibt's nicht ins Provider Geschäft zu gehen und vermutlich hätten sie spätestens dann auch irgendwelche Kartellprobleme, wenn sie jetzt auch noch anfangen äh Provider zu sein. Ähm.
Zu sein. Ja, das kann natürlich sein.
Sicherlich aber wird YouTube ein,
Multi-Milliardenkonzern, der äh weltweit agiert,
nicht Geld spenden, um sein äh Geschäftsmodell zu stärken, ohne dafür eine Gegenleistung zu bekommen. Also Google wird ja
zumindest jetzt, wenn sie einen Betrag an Orange bezahlen, eine Erwartung haben,
welchen Vorteil das dann Google bringt.
Na gut, der der Vorteil, den Google, glaube ich, für sich. Ich meine, Google ist grade total keep ich auf Afrika, aus verschiedenen Gründen, die man auch gut nachvollziehen kann. Ich meine, erstens ist es so,
Abgesehen davon, dass natürlich China explodiert. Äh Afrika und Indien natürlich auch ein Stück weit,
also auch signifikant, aber das ist ja sozusagen schon im Prozess, ja, ist in Afrika irgendwie noch alles offen, aber eigentlich gibt's auch eine ganze Menge Potential. Afrika entwickelt sich und so viel da im Argen liegen mag, es gibt einen langsamen Trend,
in Afrika äh,
zur, na ich will's jetzt nicht zu sehr aufladen, ja, aber so ein Demokratisierungs äh Prozess, so ein oder sagen wir mal, ein politischer Wandel hinzu Stabilität,
die Demokratie mal außen vor. Ja, aber da also das Kernproblem Afrikas ist ja.
Der Mangel an Stabilität, ja, ich meine es gibt ja auch andere Regionen, die jetzt aber mal im Bereich Demokratie jetzt auch nicht gerade glänzen, wo, sagen wir mal, das Mobilfunkangebot zumindest passt, ja, so Saudi-Arabien oder so, ja.
Aber Afrika hat natürlich nicht viel Geld zu investieren und dementsprechend haben die Leute dort auch noch nicht sehr viel Geld beizutragen um wirklich große äh beitragenden Netze zu finanzieren.
Würde ich zumindest jetzt sagen wir mal erstmal so halbwegs glauben. Aber es ist einfach so viel Potenzial und so viel Wachstums äh Optionen dadrin,
dass ich mich auch wunder, warum es nicht genug Wettbewerb gibt in diesen Ländern, um einfach dadurch schon äh Druck zu erzeugen, dass sie äh ihre Netze ausbauen.
Es war doch in jedem anderen Land beim zum Anfang des Beginns des Ausbaus von Mobilfunknetzen so, dass eine Refinanzierung dieses Netzes erst in Jahrzehnten,
ernsthaft ansteht
Ja, ähm in in Afrika, so wie ich das sehe, was sie also wie ich die Einführung der D und E-Netze in in Deutschland miterlebt habe, war das schon so, dass es eine einige Jahre gab, in denen das nur sehr.
Äh indes immer noch sehr, sehr teuer war. So ein, so ein Mobiltelefon zu haben
und äh bei den Zähnen sowieso schon so, aber dann kam irgendwann die D und E Netz und irgendwann äh kam
Druck auf für die Menschen, auch diese mehr Geld dafür auszugeben, ja, also auch sich sich für fünfzig Mark oder was im Monat äh Telefonanschlüsse zu holen,
In Afrika ist das anders. Die äh bauen da äh oder nach meinem,
nach meinen Beobachtungen. Kann auch sein, dass ich einfach zu spät in Afrika war. Äh da habe ich gesehen, dass dann schon,
sehr viele Menschen bemüht sind, solche Telefone zu haben. Und äh das heißt, da geht es direkt in an so einer breiteren Masse an. Aber vielleicht ähm,
Ich denke, das Thema ist hier nicht unbedingt Afrika. Ähm es ist, wie gesagt, aus der Medienberichterstattung nicht hundertprozentig klar, für welchen Traffic,
Ob das jetzt der Traffic nach Afrika ist oder der Traffic nach äh Frankreich,
Es scheint für mich so von der Lesart, dass es sich um den Traffic nach Frankreich handelt.
Also das, da, ja.
Also der Satz ist jetzt hier äh der interessant. Das Interessante ist, dass äh Google Geld an den französischen Teleg an France Telekom Orange bezahlt für die, ja, also France Telekom Orange,
muss man wissen, Orange ist ursprünglich mal aus France Telekom hervorgekommen. Äh hervorgegangen, das heißt, also,
Tatsächlich Frankreich kriegt das Geld. Ähm und wo der Traffic, also in Frankreich macht äh die Hälfte des Traffics von Orange-Usern,
Google aus,
Google Traffic aus, YouTube Traffic aus. Was, was gut sein kann, das heißt nicht, dass sie die Hälfte der Zeit mit Google Diensten verbringen, aber natürlich ist YouTube ein äh ein äh Daten aufwendiger Dienst, wenn Traffic aufwendiger Dienst,
Wenn die Nutzer den äh häufig in Anspruch nehmen, sagen wir mal nur zehn Prozent ihrer Onlinezeit, dann kann das sehr leicht ähm,
Fünfzig Prozent ihres Datenvolumens äh ausmachen.
Jetzt ist die Frage, warum ist das äh ist das gut oder ist das schlecht? Also wie gesagt, ich äh an Google-Stelle hätte ich gesagt, naja, wisst ihr was, Orange? Ähm,
Wir haben ja hier unsere, unseren Internetanschluss,
Dieser Internetanschluss von Google ist ja nicht ein, die haben ja kein DSL, sondern die haben ja äh direkte Kabel am an den Internet Exchanges liegen. Google legt meines Wissens sogar teilweise eigene Kabel, um ihre ähm,
äh Datencenter zu verbinden und dann nicht auf Internetinfrastruktur zurückgreifen zu müssen, weil ihnen die zu teuer verkauft wird?
Dann Google.
Für ihre internen Datencenter oder? Also für für die google interne Kommunikations von.
Muss einfach mal sehen, wie groß Google ist. Google ist,
Google ist quasi ein eigener ISP für sich selbst und ist international aufgestellt,
heißt, äh die sind in jedem Land vertreten und äh haben in jedem Land ein eigenes Peering und haben halt ein eigenes internationales Netz, über das sie eben ihren eigenen Traffic äh teilweise vielleicht auch über gemietete Leitungen natürlich, also,
Keine Ahnung, wie das äh Detail ist, aber sie treten eben einfach da ohnehin als ISP äh auf, also zumindest als Backboard, ISP und ähm,
haben halt alle möglichen äh Deals und bieten natürlich jedem, äh der es haben will, da irgendwie ihre Pipes an. Aber dass sie dafür bezahlen.
Der Moment, sie bezahlen ja klar, sie sie sind irgendwo am Internet Exchange und haben einen, da kommt dann der,
Man kann stellen wir uns jetzt mal wie so ein Schlauch vor, ne? Da kommt der große Gugelschlauch und aus diesem Schlauch kommt,
Erstmal sehr viel raus, ja? Da ist sehr viel Druck drauf, wenn also der Traffic, der quasi von Google
durch diese Internet zu den Providern, zu ihm wie den Nutzern geht, da ist da kommt relativ viel, ist klar. Deswegen wird Google auch zumindest an den Internet Exchanges irgendwie relativ klare äh Abkommen haben. Ich weiß nicht genau, ob das äh.
Ja, aber normalerweise sieht das halt bei den Peering Points einfach so aus, dass da einfach alle mit allem kostenneutral sich einfach vernetzen, ja. Punkt.
Gehe ich jetzt auch mal von aus, dass da dass das der Fall ist. Und jetzt geht also, jetzt kommt ein das YouTube Video kommt also irgendwie aus diesem Google,
internen Netz von dem Google Server irgendwo an einen Internet Exchange und da dann auf über mehrere Wege äh zu mir,
Und was Orange Telekom jetzt macht, ist quasi an der Stelle, wo das ähm wo dieses Video dann, sage ich mal, bei dem,
Mir Nähe nahegelegensten Internetknotenpunkt ist, in das Netz von Orange übergeht,
wo es nämlich dann irgendwie am Ende durch das Kebelchen durch den Verteilerkasten bei mir vor der Haustür durchs DSL dann irgendwann in meine Wohnung kommt. An der Stelle sagt Orange jetzt Google, weißt du was, hier ist so ein kleiner.
Aber Orange ist nur Mobilfunk, ne.
Nee, die haben auch Festnetz.
Orange hat auch noch mal Festnetz, aber das ist doch dann Frau Telekom.
Moment.
Wobei das letztlich jetzt.
Sie sind der größte, sie sind der größte äh neben SFR auf jeden Fall der größte Mobilfunk Provider auch. Aber ich glaube auch, dass sie auch, warte.
Also SFR auf jeden Fall macht beides. Ja, ADSLEFIBO haben sie auch, ja. Also die haben äh,
DSL und das sind Orange, kannst du dir vorstellen, das ist so in in einer Liga mit mit was mit der Telekom oder so, ne? Also ihr kommt ja auch von der Fonds Telekom. So, hier
ähm an dem Punkt sagt also an dem Moment, wo das wo das wo das Video schon äh den ganzen Weg hierhin geschafft hat,
sitze ich dann als Orange und sage, naja, wenn das jetzt noch zu meinen Nutzern kommt,
wird's jetzt auf einmal eng. Lieber Google und jetzt müssen wir natürlich uns darüber unterhalten, dass dass du mir irgendwie äh hilfst
Ganzen äh Internet-Traffic noch an meine Kunden durchzuleiten. Dafür muss ich irgendwie neue äh was weiß ich
GSM äh UMTS und LTE-Masten aufstellen, dafür muss ich bei mir irgendwie ordentlich Switches in den Schrank stellen, die den ganzen Kram da überhaupt noch äh verwurstet kriegen und ähm da brauche ich jetzt ein bisschen Hilfe von dir Google.
Und dann sagt Google ja, ja, was ist denn, wenn wir dir nicht helfen? Und dann sagt er oh Mensch, ja, kann das natürlich gut sein, dass äh die YouTube-Videos ruckeln bei bei meinen Kunden.
Und dann sagt der Google ja. Muss halt das Netz ausbauen. Und dann sagt der Orange, ja ähm,
Schon richtig,
Geld für, ne? So und ähm Google hat jetzt offensichtlich den, ich denke, es ist ein katastrophaler Fehler, den sie da gemacht haben, zu sagen, okay, wir bezahlen nicht dafür, weil was jetzt ist natürlich klar, dass Google,
erwartet lieber Orange, du wirst ja jetzt, ich habe dir ja Geld gegeben, das heißt, meine Videos werden ja wohl nicht mehr ruckeln oder,
und Orange ist natürlich jetzt äh sehr stark äh inzentiviert dafür zu sorgen, dass YouTube Videos nicht ruckeln, wenn Google schon Geld dafür gibt.
Also wir befinden uns jetzt schon mal sehr im freien Interpretieren, ja? Deswegen möchte ich dir ganz gerne mal eine kleine Bremse einführen, weil wir wissen's nicht genau, was das jetzt mit diesen Durchleistungsendgelden wirklich
auf sich hat und was der Deal ist und was sozusagen dadurch.
Kennen nicht den Betrag, aber wir kennen wir kennen ganz klar, dass der, dass der CEO sich damit offensiv ins Fernsehen stellt und sagt, ich bekomme Geld von Google.
Kommt Geld, ja genau, aber nicht wofür genau.
Für doch, für den Traffic, den sie durchladen. Das sagte er sogar pro äh.
Ja, aber was ist sozusagen die Garantie dafür? Ich meine, ist ja so,
nicht nur, weil sie da überhaupt treffig einleiten dürfen, kriegen sie Geld, sondern es muss ja da sozusagen auch irgendeine Bedingung,
Irgendetwas muss sich ja Google damit auch erkaufen und das wissen wir nicht. Wir wissen nicht, was die Garantie ist. Wir wissen nicht, was Orange dafür leistet.
Außer es anzunehmen, weil zum Annehmen alleine müssten sie nichts zahlen
Die Frage ist nur, gibt es dort eine Qualitätssicherung? Gibt es dort eine,
prozentual sich in Bitraten irgendwie niederschlagene konkrete Vereinbarungen und wie sieht die aus? Also das gut. Wir müssen es an der Stelle einfach offen lassen, denke ich. Äh wir prangern das jetzt erstmal so äh.
Ich möchte äh also.
Und äh ja, was möchtest du.
Ich möchte ja noch ein bisschen mehr den den Zusammenhang äh verdeutlichen. Also warum ist das jetzt überhaupt schlecht? Man könnte ja sagen,
und das hatte da heute Morgen ein Gespräch noch drüber, dass man sagt, ist doch super, ne? Google ist oft relativ offensichtlich der Anbieter, der es notwendig macht, das,
Internetinfrastruktur oder auch Provider Infrastruktur, die im Datenvolumen angepasst wird, was,
was da an Nachfrage besteht. Ähm da ist doch toll, wenn sie sich dann auch da daran beteiligen, dass dass das auch äh,
Dass die Provider in der Lage sind, das bereitzustellen. Die Alternative ist ja,
Wenn man jetzt davon ausgeht, dass äh Orange Telekom sich verkalkuliert hat und tatsächlich nicht,
Aus eigener äh aus eigener äh aus eigener Kraft in der Lage ist, die Netze so auszubauen, dass sie die Verträge, die sie mit ihren Kunden haben,
erfüllen können, was die das die Bandbreite angeht, die der Kunde bestellt hat äh und so weiter, dass wenn Orange nicht in der Lage ist, das zu erfüllen, dann ist das ja zunächst einfach mal nur Oranges-Problem.
So ungefähr so als müssten Calls hätte dafür bezahlen, dass äh hier in meiner äh Nebenstelle äh die Erlangen ausgebaut werden. Ähm damit damit, damit bei diesem Callcitter genug angerufen werden kann.
Das ist doch total irre.
Genau, es ist total irre und was heißt, was heißt, was ist die Folge davon, sie implizierte Folge, ist natürlich, dass Google irgendetwas da da als Gegenleistung haben möchte. Sie machen, Google ist genauso ein Unternehmen wie alle anderen auch, die machen das nicht aus karitativen Erwägungen
So und die die Erwartung ist doch selbstverständlich, dass äh Google dadurch ein äh ein Anspruch auf Vorteil gegenüber der Konkurrenz hat
oder einen impliziten Anspruch hat. Oder als Google, der zumindest die erste der Erste wäre, der sich,
mit äh mit robustem Mandat beschweren kann, wenn sein Traffic nicht mehr vernünftig.
Dass es äh richtig und ähm die Frage ist auch wirklich, was ist sozusagen die Konsequenz für die anderen, ja?
Genau und die Konsequenz für die anderen es ist naheliegend, dass die Konsequenz für die anderen ist, dass da ab einer gewissen Größe,
dann eventuell auch, sagt ja, Freunde, hm, wir haben leider jetzt schon äh fünfzig Prozent Google, ähm die haben übrigens die bezahlenden Netzausbau bei uns ein bisschen mit. Ähm,
Ich könnte mir natürlich vorstellen, dass wir noch ein bisschen mehr Netzausbau betreiben müssten, um die Videovideos jetzt auch noch unseren Kunden zustellen zu können.
Da würde sich dann das äh,
Geschäftsmodell für den Provider rantieren, der dann wie äh an an dieser Stelle zwischen Internet und Kunde sitzt und in beide Richtungen kassiert, weil eigentlich ja alles bezahlt sein sollte, laut Vertrag, den ich mit dem,
mit meinem Internet Provider habe.
Fünfzig Prozent des Datenvolumens sei Google. Das ist echt eine Menge Holz.
Ja, aber ich, wie gesagt, ich gehe so, er hat zweihundertdreißig Millionen Kunden, das heißt, er äh meint, dass äh weltweite äh äh weltweite Volumen des Konzerns, ne.
Alle Netze. Krass.
Ja, keine äh keine positive Entwicklung, weil wenn das jetzt Schule macht, wir wissen, dass die Telekom in Deutschland seit längerer Zeit an genau solchen Regelungen Interesse hat. Die äh tritt da relativ offen äh,
für auf, es erklärt außerdem im Rückblick für mich sehr interessant,
Ich hatte mich damals auf Netzpolitik Org damit viele auseinandergesetzt, der äh die,
Regelungen zur Netzneutralität in den USA, ne, wo sie gesagt haben, was ist äh Netzwerk, wie wollen wir die Waren und so weiter. Da war Google sehr stark äh drin involviert.
Hat die aber bis zu einem gewissen Rahmen auch äh dann abgeschwächt äh insbesondere was dem Mobilfunkbereich, der ist da komplett ausgeschlossen und so. Ähm.
Ja, ich
Google sollte sich wäre mal ganz interessant, äh dass das hier nachgefasst wird. Ich gehe ja mal davon äh aus, dass der ein oder andere Journalist da vielleicht nochmal ein paar äh gezieltere Fragen stellen sollte, weil die,
Fragestellung, die ich jetzt im Kopf habe, ist halt vor allem so,
Was ist Google Statements dazu? Ja, also was äh was bedeutet das für ihre eigene Linie im Bezug äh Netzneutralität? Ist das jetzt sozusagen aufgegeben, ja?
Die werden sehr unglücklich sein, dass der Typ das.
Kaufen die sich da und ist das vor allem katellrechtlich bereits äh schon irgendwie relevant, ja? Also wird hier in einer Form da äh,
irgendein Datenübertragungsmonopol äh hergestellt. Das.
Wir müssen uns auch mal erklären lassen, inwieweit sowas wirklich als Problem angesehen werden kann, dass,
Google fünfzig Prozent des Treffings macht, weil letzten Endes ist es ja eigentlich auch egal. Die Nachfrage nach dem Inhalten ist ja eigentlich unabhängig von dem Anbieter,
Wenn die Leute die Videos sehen wollen und die liegen nun mal alle bei YouTube, mein Gott, dann liegen sie halt alle bei YouTube, aber würden sie morgen nicht mehr bei YouTube liegen, dann liegen sie halt bei mir oder sonst irgendwo und dann würden sie immer noch geguckt werden wollen. Das ist halt einfach die Nachfrage,
äh deswegen äh geht es alles gar nicht.
Das ist ausführlich in Ordnung. Äh dann sei noch weil wir die Schweiz, wir haben ja gesagt, wir wollen uns auf die Schweiz konzentrieren
in der Schweiz ist Orange auch tätig als Netzanbieter, ich erwähnt jetzt glaube ich gerade sogar und da haben sie jetzt auch die diesen Spotify Deal, ja? Den gleichen, den wir hier in Deutschland haben
die Kooperation, dass also dieses dieser Daten
Traffic, der von Spotify kommt, dann äh anders abgerechnet wird als restlicher Daten-Traffic. Damit halt auch wieder so eine äh,
nachteilige Situation auf dem Wettbewerb äh geschaffen wird für Konkurrenten von Spotify. Ja, also,
Da sieht man schon eine ganz klare Linie, dass äh man bei Orange offensichtlich äh sich zum Ziel gesetzt hat, diese Position, die man hat zwischen den Anbietern und dem,
Und den und den also den Inhalt der Anbietern und den Konsumenten ähm,
diese Position da durchaus zu monetarisieren.
Ja, man merkt auch, dass es eigentlich in zunehmendem Maße einen Bedarf bedarf für eine europäische Regelung äh zu des Neutralität einfach äh gibt und wir warten gespannt ab, sich das ergibt.
Auch äh eine europäische Regelung zu geben sollte. Wir haben das ja hier mehrfach behandelt, war zum äh internationalen äh,
Terrorismus im Internet, der musste ja äh bekämpft werden, wie die ähm EU,
äh in einem finanzierten Forschungsprojekt oder in einer Beratungsprojekt oder was auch immer, das da jetzt genau war. Wir hatten das ja äh ausführlich behandelt, auch zusammen mit Andre. Und dieses Projekt hat jetzt äh relativ still,
seinen Abschlussbericht vorgelegt. Und ähm der sollte natürlich hier auch äh Erwähnung finden,
Ist ein relativ wenige Seiten, umfassendes Dokument insgesamt einundzwanzig Seiten äh sind davon ernsthaft bedruckt und davon sind dann nochmal äh drei, vier,
sechs Seiten oder so fünf oder sechs Seiten so große Zwischenüberschriften, weil so eine Überschrift auf die gesamte Seite geschrieben wurde. Also ein relativ kurzer kurzes Dokument, welches ähm definieren möchte,
wie man den Terrorismus im Internet reduzieren kann und.
Dazu best practicees nennt. Man kennt das, also Best Practice,
Äh also eine eine unverbindliche Benennung der des des,
Goldstandard des in der äh in im Umgang mit mit dem Problem des des Internets. Äh des des Internetterrorismus. Da haben sie erstmal eine lange ähm.
Lange äh Einführung, in der sie äh im Prinzip immer wieder entschuldigen,
dass sie hier, dass es hier keine Richtlinie ist und dass sie nicht das Internet zensieren wollen und so. Also sie entschuldigen sich erstmal äh oder wenden sich erstmal auf mehreren Seiten gegen die äh Kritik, die dem ganzen Projekt ja schon entgegengeschlagen ist.
Sagen, sie wollen also ein konstruktiven Dialog hier ähm und,
grundsätzliche Prinzipien äh benennen und Best Practices definieren. Und so ist auch dieses Dokument dann aufgebaut. Sie beginnen erstmal mit so einer Definitionssache, wo sie sagen,
Also wo sie erst mal Terrorismus äh definieren und sagen, wie der im Internet zum tragen kommt, ja. Sagen also, Terrorismus sind,
beabsichtigte Handlungen, die in in ihrem Kontext ähm.
Einen ein Land oder eine internationale Organisation äh ernsthaft schädigen können,
und mit dem Ziel begangen werden, eine Bevölkerung zu einzuschüchtern, ähm,
eine Regierung oder eine internationale Organisation äh zu einer Handlung zu zwingen oder zu zwingen, von einer Handlung abzusehen,
oder das politische System zu destabilisieren. Das ist ungefähr die die simultan Übersetzung beim Lesen jetzt, wie sie, wie sie Terrorismus definieren. Und sagen, ähm im Internet kann also,
Äh Terrorismus sich dadurch äußern, dass man öffentlich äh terroristische Akte provoziert,
durch äh Radikalisierung, Propaganda oder äh Glorifizierung von von von Artentätern.
Ähm oder schlechte Politik.
Das schlechte schlechte Leute rekrutiert
trainiert äh oder äh tatsächlicher terroristische Handlung plant und organisiert, also zum Beispiel man hat so einen Red Mine aufgesetzt, in dem in dem man dann ein ein Attentat plant, ja.
So, dagegen wollen sie, wollen sie also vorgehen und und schlagen, schlagen dann äh sehr interessante,
äh Wege vor das zu tun. Und äh wenn du Lust hast, Tim, können wir äh dir mal kurz vorstellen und kommentieren.
Vorstellen und kommentieren.
Die Best practices of äh die General Principus of Best practices of reducing Terrorist, Activity on the Internet.
Genau, ja das das betrübt mich ja schon lange, dass ich eigentlich keine richtige Vorstellung habe ähm.
Ja, also der, sie sagen.
Dagegen vorgehen kann.
Punkt E ist äh in der Präambel heißt es zu Punkt E. Wenn man den die terroristische Benutzung des Internets senkt, dann wird es auch die terroristischen Aktivitäten mindern,
und die Wahrscheinlichkeit von Terrorangriffen. Deswegen müssen wir das machen. Ja, weil das stand ja auch längere Zeit äh
Frage äh warum man das machen muss also. Also, was machen wir jetzt gegen die Terroristen?
Wir haben also hier Best Practices, so und da steht nochmal betont, dass das jetzt äh das soll einfach als Guideline dienen, das heißt, jeder soll soll soll halt sehen, was von der EU Kommission als Best Practice definiert ist. Das wird jetzt nicht irgendwie legisativ,
umgesetzt. Und da gibt's also sie unterteilen das in in proaktive Maßnahmen in äh.
Maßnahmen, also äh wie man tatsächlich, wenn es schon passiert ist, darüber Menschen informiert und wie man dann reagiert, ja?
Und sie sagen, ja, also äh proaktive Maßnahme, man braucht einen Leader Framework, ja und da gibt es äh das Wichtigste ist, dass das ähm,
Dass das Legal Framework, welches ein Land dann implementiert, äh Nutzern, NGOs und äh Offforitys und Internetanbietern ähm,
klar erklärt wird, damit sie es effektiv anwenden können, ja? Also ein, ein, ein Nichtsatz, ja, hätte man auch rauslassen können.
Ja? Zweiter Punkt, den man braucht, ist äh Government Policys,
Und das heißt, äh dass äh man sich äh gutes Equipment macht und die Kooperation zwischen Internetanbietern,
und NGOs und ähm der Regierung stärkt, um Terrorismusnutzung des Internets äh zu reduzieren. Auch hier ähm ein ein Nichtsatz,
Teil drei, sehr schön,
Man muss entsprechende AGBs haben, in den AGBs muss stehen, dass äh terroristische äh Internetterrorismus Unexeptable ist auf einer Plattform.
Terrorismus verboten.
Ja, Terrorismusverbot muss in den AGB.
Ah, ganz einfach, ne? Das äh mein Gott, das hätten wir hätten wir früher draufkommen. Ja.
Hätten wir früher drauf kommen müssen. Und sagen, ja, dann sagen sie aber, einige Internetcompanies ähm entforschen diese Policy auch effektiv, ja, also da da wird's dann also,
Hier steckt der Teufel dann in dem Detail, wo sie also empfehlen, na ja, die AGBs musst du natürlich dann auch jetzt umsetzen, ja.
Ja, das gehört natürlich schon äh dazu. Da kommen dann wahrscheinlich die internationale Superheldenliga der Abmahnanwälte.
Genau, die haben da sicherlich, die helfen dann bei.
Ja, die sollte man mal auf die Terroristen hetzen. Dahinten die wirklich mal eine harte Zeit.
Da kriegt der damit machst du die Jungs fertig. Ja.
Ja, die haben allerlei ich meine wahrscheinlich auch tonnenweise Copyreiht äh Verletzungen, damit ihren Bekennervideos und so, ne, wo so bestimmt das ein oder andere Urheberrecht äh verletzt wurde und ich meine, selbst wenn nicht, man kann das ja auch erstmal behaupten.
Vor allem da entzieht man dann dem dem Terrorismus auch seine finanzielle Basis,
Und ich denke, dass Abmahnanwälte sowieso mit, dass mit die gemeinste Facette unserer Gesellschaft sind, insofern können wir die echt mal auf die Terroristen hetzen. Ich finde das ein ist echt ein Vorschlag.
Dann würden wir uns wahrscheinlich auch äh extreme äh Kostenersparnis äh so im Bereich GSG9 et cetera äh dann auch noch in der Folge äh uns haben schreiben.
Das ist ein Vorschlag, wir müssen das unbedingt dann denen noch sagen, dass wir da äh dass wir das machen, ja?
Abmahnanwälte in die Produktion. An die Front.
So, dann gibt's äh irgendwie äh Awareness muss man auch machen. Awareness Programme, also komm, also ich meine, da braucht man gar nicht zu diskutieren, ja? Also man muss,
Programm heißt ja Angst schüren, ne, das ist das ist ein Awareness-Programm im politischen Bereich, ist das die ja, also äh Angst muss man auch schüren,
So und dann kommen wir auch schon zu zu Teil zwei, nämlich den,
Also äh sie haben eingesehen, dass das Internet zu groß ist, um äh es komplett zu erkennen. Und dass man ähm dafür sorgen muss, dass dass die Leute,
wenn man kennt, dass man surft so durchs Internet und völlig, völlig äh überraschend ohne jede Erwartung auf einmal Terrorismus,
Terrorismusplanung, ja? Und da soll der Nutzer natürlich etwas an der Hand haben,
nämlich diesen äh diese Inhalte zu pflegen, ja? Das ist äh ich glaube, da stellen sich sowas vor wie wie bei YouTube, dass man sagen kann, dieser Fleck ist, Content ist und da kann man dann.
Konntet es.
Ihr Terrorismus, ne.
Terrorismuswimpel.
Ja, also sie, sie haben das äh
wir sind da jetzt noch quasi in der Plattform selber, also sowas wie das Facebook quasi äh und äh so YouTube oder was dann eben eine Möglichkeit bieten sollen für den Anwender, diesen diese Inhalte zu markieren,
Ja? Das ist also dann auf der Plattform selber, weil ja äh also da geht's dann, wie gesagt, ich denke, das, wo sie, wo sie jetzt hier dran denken, wer hat so einen Terrorismusvideo auf auf YouTube, ne? Das wird sagen, kannst hier nicht in Ordnung ist Touris.
Keine Sterne, keine Herzchen mehr, sondern irgendwie äh äh Messer äh im Rücken, äh kleine Icons, ja,
und dann schaltet man halt äh Antifa dazwischen, der die dann halt auch gleich entsprechend ausschaltet so.
Sowas sowas genau und dann hat natürlich jemand gesagt, na ja, was machen wir denn dann mit den Plattformen? Hm, die das nicht,
anbieten. Und da haben sie eine sehr schöne Idee. Da freue ich mich noch sehr drauf. Eine ein,
und da sollst du quasi die Möglichkeit bekommen, äh dieser dieser Knopf soll also da äh eventuell nicht auf jeder Seite eingebaut ist. Ich meine, ich werde in meinem Blog sofort irgendwie
Reportingmechanismus für terroristische Inhalte einbauen. Aber nicht jeder Terrorist ist so,
so interessiert an den Best Practices zur Terrorismusbekämpfung, wie ich. Ja, das heißt, ähm deswegen muss der technisch natürlich dieser Button im Browser sein.
Firefox vor, zurück, Neuladen, Stopp, Terrorismus, ja? Oben in der.
Ja oder gleich Feier. Ich meine, das ist eh schlimm Firefox ist, könnte man ja auch mal einen Open Fire.
Hier brenn.
Ja. Hier einfach direkt schießen.
Feier, ja.
Ja, man kann, man, man könnte, wenn man die Webseiten eh schon offen hat, dann kann man ja auch gleich drauf schießen. Warum kommt denn auf sowas eigentlich kein,
Ist doch so naheliegend, ja. Warum warum erst noch ein Wimpel? Ja das ist ja so was, als ob du ein Bankraub beobachtest, ja? Und dann hängst du erstmal den Bankräuber einen Wimpel äh um,
einfach gleich abknallen.
Ja, das ist eine Lösung,
oder aber äh Best Practice Nummer sieben. Ähm eine Hotline. Ich meine, kannst dir die Hotline vorstellen. Bei der Hotline willst du ja nicht arbeiten, ne?
Terrorismus-Hotline.
Der Terrorismus hat nein. Ähm wo man dann anruft und sagt, äh hallo, ich bin hier äh im Internet grade über ein ähm,
Terroristen gestolpert. Ich sage ihnen das mal durch, das ist HTTP. Ja. Doppelpunkt Schrägstrich Schrägstrich so und so Punkt com Schräge Schrägstrich Fragezeichen HL gleich.
Ja, erstmal die IPV sechs Adresse äh ja, komplett. Ja, FE acht null äh vier,
ABD eins neun sechs was gut.
Ja? Das erinnert mich an dieses äh Aussteigerprogramm für Linksextreme, ne? Kennst du dich jetzt nicht daran erinnern?
Irgendwie vierunddreißig Anrufe in einem Jahr und irgendwie zweiunddreißig davon waren Scherzanrufe oder so und einer hatte sich verwählt und andere hat aufgelegt oder ihm so.
Ja, ich denke, mit den Zahlen können die dann locker mithalten, ne?
Ja. Ja, so, also eine äh Hotline.
Hammer, also ich bin froh, dass ich die EU einfach auch um sowas kümmert, weil ich fühle mich jetzt schon viel sicherer auch.
Ich wollte vor allem äh eigentlich nochmal raussuchen, was dieses, was dieses Dokument jetzt gekostet hat. Äh es war ja irgendwie der Betrag war ja benannt. Ich weiß nur nicht mehr genau, wie viele, das war ja natürlich irgendwie ein paar hunderttausend Euro, aber ähm,
Ich weiß nicht mehr, äh,
Vielleicht kann ich das noch schnell rausholen, was das IT-Projekt äh wie viel Geld die da bekommen haben. Äh EDI hat da eine,
Äh äh.
Naja, also es gab natürlich irgendwo, es ist öffentlich, wie viel Geld sie dafür bekommen haben, das war relativ viel. Also die einzelne Seite, die ich hier vorlese, ist, ähm relativ teure, te.
Sind jetzt diese clean IT Geschichte damit jetzt auch offiziell äh beerdigt? Das ist das Ergebnis. Das ist das Ergebnis. Das Ergebnis.
Das ist jetzt, das ist das Ergebnis, das das ist das Ergebnis. Dazu dafür haben die das gemacht. Aber es.
Klingt so ein bisschen wie so ein Sammelband von Internetideen der CDU der letzten zehn Jahre.
Das kommt ja noch besser. Es kommt ja noch besser. Wir waren ja jetzt noch immer nur bei den Reporting Best Practices, wo sie so schlaue Ideen hatten, wie ein, wie ein Button und eine Hotline. So, jetzt kommen wir zu den reaktiven Best Practices. Also, wie reagiere ich
wenn es dann da ist? Und da geht's natürlich dann sagen sie okay da haben sie äh tatsächlich eine eine schlaue Idee gehabt.
Action.
Ja, genau. Rufst bei den Providern und sagst, ey Jungs, da die die Büchse hier da äh stehen habt, da ist irgendwie Scheiße drauf, ähm macht das mal weg.
Ja, das ist was Neues? Nö.
Nee, ist nicht nice. Gab's schon, gibt's schon lange, ja. Äh Best Practice neun, Points of Contacts, ja, das also äh.
Man weiß nicht, wen man anrufen soll. Wie genau, man weiß äh.
Wie genau? Man weiß äh dass vor allem die die Regierungen äh Internet äh Anbieter und so nicht immer wissen, wen sie, wen sie äh,
kontaktieren sollen, wenn Terroris News auf die Internet äh festgestellt wurde und ähm.
Na, ich dachte, dafür gibt's das rote Telefon.
Gibt's da ein rotes, also ein rotes Telefon? Und äh haben wir nicht irgendwie in Deutschland gibt's doch auch irgendwelche irgendjemanden, den man anrufen kann oder so. Innenministerium oder seid ihr bestimmt eine Hotline, wo ich sagen kann, hier äh.
Geht's jetzt dadrum, wo man anruft bei der Regierung oder geht's dadrum, wo die Regierung äh anruft? Man geht daran, wo man anruft. Ich würde sagen, einfach direkt im Kanzleramt.
Ja, ich glaube, sie empfehlen hier.
Experten, die ihre Organisation repräsentieren, möglichst vierundzwanzig sieben,
Ah, okay. Nee, sie wollen im Prinzip, dass jeder Internetanbieter quasi den Terrorismus beauftragten hat, äh,
Und äh jede NGO oder was auch immer
und die sollten ah genau, also hauptsächlich in den Firmen dann auch. Und das ist das BSI, das Bundesamt für sich hat in der Informationstechnik oder als Bundesinnenministerium in einem solchen Falle, dann äh jemanden hat zum Anruf. Also es ist etwas anders als die.
NGOs auch.
Ja, zum Beispiel, also du bist ja hier alles irgendwie so NGO, Internet Company, NGOs, Health Points of Contacts force of the Internet.
Warum denn die NGOs?
Also ich finde das ja auch etwas verwirrend formuliert, ja, weil sie als Herausforderung sagen sie ja, irgendwie die Governments und so weiter wissen nicht, wen sie anrufen sollen,
sei, sie sollen welche haben, aber nicht, dass sie selber welche bieten, sondern dass sie sozusagen davon Kenntnis erhalten.
Eine Liste haben sollen. Also sie sollen im Prinzip.
Wen sie anrufen sollen.
Genau, sie sie stellen sich, glaube ich, in jeder größeren,
jeder Größe in die Regierung äh Behörden, Internetcompanies und NGOs Terrorismus.
Nein, die sollen gesagt bekommen, wo sie anrufen sollen, wenn es denn soweit ist. So, ja okay, dann sage ich einfach direkt Kanzleramt anrufen. Nee, guck mal.
Nee, nee, guck mal. Äh New Work of Trusted in Listed Points of Contacts für experte.
Ja, du sollst sozusagen für die ISPs entsprechende ISP, das, das ist alles Quatsch.
Also jeder soll einen Terrorismusbeauftragten haben so. Und der soll.
Die NGOs.
Ja, aber die müssen auch, die sollen die Liste haben, wen sie anrufen können.
Ein Telefonbuch. Sie möchten gerne einen Terrorismusbeauftragten, Telefonbuch für NGOs und Internetcompanies haben, damit die wissen, wen sie anrufen sollen. Und da rufen die dann an und dann ist gut.
Gut, ähm.
Das schmerzt. Müssen wir da hier wirklich durch die ganze Liste noch äh durchgehen.
Jetzt sind wir äh wir sind gleich fertig, jetzt haben wir's fast durch, ja. Ähm,
Sie wollen dann eine Kooperation zwischen den zwischen den notwendigen Shareholdern oder sowas. Information soll geteilt werden, ja? Es ist alles irgendwie äh auch jetzt nicht besonders äh klar getrennt. Und
Best practice Nummer zwölf. Freiwillige Enduser Control Services, das heißt Terrorismus äh Filter,
äh den ich mir auf dem Computer installiere. Ich frage mich, wie das jetzt unter der, also ähm wenn sie davon ausgehe, dass Terroristen das Internet nutzen,
und sagen, das muss eingedämmt werden,
Wie wird diesem Problem irgendwie begegnet, wenn ich mir auf mein MacBook hier einen Terrorismusfilter schalte?
Der den Terrorismus rausfiltert
Wie wird heißt das dann scheiße? Der Linus hat äh der Linus kann das nicht sehen, weil weil der ein ein filtert gegen Terrorismus auf seinem Browser hat. Also machen wir das nicht mehr?
Also es ist ja völlig lächerlich, äh als wenn ich mir freiwillig einen Terrorismusfilter installieren würde als Terrorist.
Ja, es ist ungefähr so, als ob man was dagegen tun wollte, dass so viele Arme äh äh in der Stadt zu sehen sind, so viele Obdachlose, dass man dann halt einfach an alle Bürger äh Sonnenbrillen.
Oder so Brillen, die ab unten zusehen, dass sie nicht äh ja,
Äh und dann gibt es noch die, also genau so, wir sollen jetzt alle Terrorismusfilter installieren, keine Ahnung, was das helfen soll und äh dann gibt's noch die Best Practice Punkt vier, Learning und da heißt es also, man soll einen akademisches Netzwerk zur,
Erforschung des Internet,
Terrorismus äh bereitstellen. Und ich denke, das wäre tatsächlich notwendig gewesen, um ein halbwegs geistreiches Dokument zu formulieren. Das stellen sie am Ende des Dokumentes fest und sagen, da müsste man eigentlich mal.
Eigentlich hätten wir mal nachdenken sollen.
Dran schicken. Da müsste man mal jemanden dranschicken, der sich damit auskennt. Ja, das ist tatsächlich das, was sie hier sagen hier.
Ja. Oh Mann, ey.
Ja, also ein akademisches Netzwerk muss geschaffen werden, um da mal sich ernsthaft Gedanken drüber zu machen. Das ist, denke ich, auch die klare Essenz dieses Dokumentes und wir sehen clean IT ähm,
wirkt und dir große, die große Aufregung um dieses äh Thema äh vor allem dadurch gerechtfertigt, was da für eine Kohle, für was für einen Scheiß verbrannt wurde.
Ich liefere in der nächsten Sendung nochmal nach, was da eine Seite von dem Ding gekostet hat.
Gut, kommen wir äh nochmal zur deutschen Belangen, wenn ich das richtig sehe, ne. Unser Standard Aufregerthema.
Aufregerthema ähm.
Das ist äh sehr spannend, weil wir erinnern uns ja, ich weiß gar nicht, äh hat Google noch die Kampagne, verteidige deine Presse, äh verteidige dein Netz oder was? Wenn man jetzt auf Google kommt? Äh Google DE,
Haben sie noch nicht mal mehr.
Nö, das war jetzt nur dieser merkwürdigen Sitzungen, die damals da stattgefunden hat.
Ist also jetzt vorbei. So, also die die Google-Kampagne verteidige dein Netz ist vorbei und,
pünktlich zum Ende dieser Kampagne veröffentlicht dann der Verband der Zeitungsverleger die Gegenkampagne. Verband deutscher Zeitschriftenverleger, die Gegenkampagne,
mit dem kreativen Namen verteidige deine Presse. Und antwortet damit auf die,
In Anführungszeichen Fakten äh gegen einen Leistungsschutzrecht, die von Google in im Rahmen seiner Kampagne äh behauptet werden. Und äh das ist also eigentlich ein größerer Blogpost, den sie da jetzt veröffentlicht haben.
Also um's kurz zu nochmal zu korrigieren, die Kampagne als solche ist definitiv noch online. Sie ist lediglich nicht auf Google DE verlinkt. Ja.
Ah
Äh ja, mehr als zwei Komma sechs Millionen beobachten die Initiative,
weiß nicht ganz genau, zwei Komma sechs Millionen was, ja? Wahrscheinlich Menschen. Und über hundertfünfzigtausend unterstützen sie aktiv und wie man rechts oben sehen kann, dreihundertvierzig schreiben das auf Google Plus. Also.
Dreihundertfünfzig.
Vierzig, vierzig, nicht übertreiben, ja? Also scheint auch extrem erfolgreich äh zu sein. Ähm so und jetzt soll aber die die Presse verteidigt werden.
Ja, die muss die muss jetzt verteidigt werden gegen diese Kampagne. Es ist also wir.
Da sind sie ja jetzt aber auch schnell dabei, ne?
Haben Sie blitzschnell reagiert? Ähm.
Mhm. Ähm so und das macht der Verband deutscher Zeitschriften verlieb.
Kannst du mal ganz kurz äh ich hätte fast den Eindruck, dass du gerade meinen Computer bedienst. Sind auf jeden Fall gerade alle Fans dazu gegangen.
Vielleicht deinen Browser gestorben? Hast du den Terrorismusfilter schon.
Beweg nochmal bitte deinen Finger auf deinem nee okay.
So weit ist es, soweit soweit ist es noch nicht, Linus.
Ich weiß es nicht. Er hat äh irgendwas, er hat dann hat eine Taste geklemmt oder so. Ähm.
Terrorismusfilter hat wahrscheinlich zugeschlagen, das ist wahrscheinlich auf die falsche Seite draufgeklickt und dann geht die gleich wieder weg.
Gespeichert hier? Nee, guck mal, ist ja interessant, ist ja stark. Äh irgendwas war mit meinem Computer.
Okay, also die VDZ, ich kann ja mal ein bisschen übernehmen, Verband deutscher,
Zeitschriftenverleger hat also jetzt diese Kampagne gestartet, verteidige deine Presse, ja, unsere, unser aller Presse,
explizit eben gegen diese Verteidiger Netz, weil Presse ist ja wichtiger als das Netz, wissen wir ja alle, ne,
Und ähm ja, was äh haben sie da jetzt sozusagen vorzubringen.
Sie haben eine, sie haben eine lange Liste und ich ich finde, man sollte der durchaus mal zumindest dadurch rechnen, dass man sie mal kurz,
sie sagen also Google behauptet dass jeder Verlag heute schon selbst entscheiden kann ob seine Seiten von von Google gefunden werden, das ist diese Geschichte. Wir erinnern uns die Steinzeittechnologie, ja?
Die Google da nutzt,
Und da wird interessanterweise die äh Behauptung oder die die Behauptung aufgestellt, dass äh von den Verlagen es ein quasi einen Vorschlag gibt für eine bessere äh,
für eine ähm RobotsTXT, die den Ansprüchen der Verlagen mehr entsprechen würde, also quasi so eine Roberts TXD zwei null.
Sie vorgeschlagen, war mir gar nicht bekannt. Es gibt aber tatsächlich da einen Blogpost von ähm,
von Christoph Käse, dem äh Springer Lobbyisten, der also sagt, so und so sähe eine,
Lesbare rechte Sprache aus, die den Ansprüchen der Verlage äh gerecht wird. Ja, hat ja relativ ausführlich ähm,
gewerbliche Kopien erlaubt, nicht erlaubt, Preis für die gewerbliche,
Kopie maximaler Anzahl gewerblicher Kopien, Weitergabe an Privatpersonen erlaubt gewerbliche Teaser erlaubt nicht erlaubt,
irgendwie grob mal definiert, was ihm so alles einfällt. Ähm das heißt, da haben sie zumindest den Punkt, dass sie,
Mal eine bessere oder dass sie einen Vorschlag machen, wie es äh aussehen wollte,
soll Tee.
Vorschlag machen das gut. Sie verweisen hier auf Protokoll. Das äh ist jetzt auch nichts neues, sondern das äh gibt es äh seit zweitausendsieben und hat seitdem
sozusagen noch nicht so sehr viel oder zweitausendsechs ist es glaube ich sogar entstanden.
Ja, das ist mal so vorgeschlagen worden, hat sich offensichtlich nicht sonderlich gut durchgesetzt,
Ist halt von der Publishers SOCation mal vorgeschlagen worden. Das wäre doch mal ganz schön, wenn man das mal machen würde. Zweitausendsieben hatten sie dann die erste Version fertig.
Aber immerhin ähm muss ich äh zugeben, dass es mir nicht klar war, dass es da oder dass ich das mir nicht bekannt war aufgrund der Google Propaganda, war mir nicht bekannt, dass es tatsächlich da Vorschläge gibt.
Erik Schmidt hat sich da wohl schon mal zu geäußert. Zweitausendacht und Mainz, es würde gerade nicht so richtig äh dazu passen, wie unsere Systeme funktionieren. Und sie würden das dann wohl eher nicht machen.
Mhm.
Dann sagen sie äh behandeln sie ihren Anspruch da was den Traffic angeht und dass dass sie, dass die Gefahr ist, dass für die kurzen News, die Leute nur auf Google News gehen und gar nicht mehr den ganzen Artikel
lesen und äh aus diesem Grunde der äh Gewinn für die der Anzeigen Trafficgewinn
für die, für den äh Verlag vollständig ausbleibt, ja, ist durchaus ein Problem. Die Frage ist, welches äh Ausmaß das hat,
dann sagt ja Google, dass äh vier Millionen Arbeitsplätze am Internet hängen in dieser Kampagne,
Also in dieser Kampagne behauptet nicht, nicht in der an der Kampagne hängen nicht vier Millionen, aber in der Kampagne sagt, Google das vier Millionen deutsche Arbeitsplätze am Internet hängen und da sagt ähm,
wehren sich dann die, wehrt sich der Verband der Zeitungsverlege, Zeitschriftenverleger und sagen, ja, aber natürlich äh insbesondere auch in unserem Bereich und außerdem geht es ja
ähm nur um unseren, um unseren kommerziellen Bereich, wir wollen nicht äh den Bloggern Probleme machen,
ähm und betont so ein bisschen diesen äh Lexkugel-Charakter.
Keinerlei Schaden erleiden die Blogger. Das ist natürlich totaler Blödsinn. Natürlich, wenn sie dadurch Schaden erleiden, dann alle Schaden erleiden. Ja.
Na sie, aber du hast genau, was sie, also sie sie führen die äh,
Argumentation hier ähnlich wie ich das auch schon ja mal nannte, so dass sie über die quasi monopolistische Struktur des äh des Anbieter von Google argumentieren ähm,
und dass es ihnen darum geht, dass sie, es geht lediglich darum, dass Suchmaschinen und Aggregatoren den Verlag vorher fragen müssen. Ja, vorher fragen müssen, ist witzig, weil äh das klingt natürlich sehr, sehr nett,
Aber vorher fragen müssen heißt ja auch, dass die Antwort eine Rechnung ist.
Also das so, sie stellen das ja hier so so gemütlich da, ne? Ja. Ähm.
Ey, ich meine in gewisser Hinsicht wird ja schon äh gefragt. Es wird halt äh von den Suchmaschinen gefragt, habt ihr eine Robots TXT? Äh was dürfen wir haben, was dürfen wir nicht haben? Und die Antwort ist ja, nimmt doch einfach alles. Peng, das alte Lied.
Aber genau da, da wollen sie ja, sie wollen ja ihr einfach,
Sie wollen ja im Prinzip, dass in der Roberts Textil steht fünf Mark. Nimm alles, du musst alles nehmen, du darfst das nicht nicht nehmen und du musst uns Geld geben. Das ist ja im Prinzip die Roberts Texte, die sie haben wollen.
Ja
Und dann widersprechen sie äh,
widersprechen sie noch feststellen, dass es eben auf Google News keine Werbung gibt, weil Google ja auch Google Plus hätte
Ja, ich weiß nicht genau, ob ihnen klar ist, dass Google Plus ein soziales Netzwerk ist. Das heißt, wenn sie da jetzt noch irgendwie
Leistungsschutzrecht auf Google ausdehnen wollen. Also sie, wie sie,
Sie widersprechen der Aussage auf Google News gibt es keine Werbung mit der Feststellung, Google bietet die journalistischen Inhalte nicht nur auf Google News an,
sondern auch auf anderen Plattformen, in dessen Konglumerat, auf denen mit Verlinkungen und hohen Nutzer Zahlen sehr wohl Geld verdient wird. Wie auf Google Plus?
Oh, sehr schön.
Plus wird Geld verdienen?
Nee, werden genau, würde also angeblich Geld verdient und außerdem äh
äh führen da ionalistische Inhalte benutzt. Ich weiß nicht, Google Plus hat wahrscheinlich auch so eine vor, so eine Preview für einen Link, den man da teilt. Es wird aber noch spannender,
zudem verdient Google über letztlich indirekt wenn die Nutzer auf die Artikel klicken,
die auf Seiten führen, auf denen verwendet wird. Das heißt, sie argumentieren jetzt der der Verband der Zeitschrift Verleger argumentiert dagegen.
Dass wenn sie selber nutzen. Weil sie selber das nutzen.
Weil sie nutzen. Ja.
Und das aha.
Also sie, sie sagen im Prinzip Google News, verdient deshalb,
mit also Google verdient deshalb mit Google News Werbung, weil wenn jemand auf den Link klickt, dann er auf einer Seite landet, wo ätzends ist und dann verdienen sie Geld.
Google darf sozusagen nicht an der Bereitstellung der äh Werbedienstleistung mitverdienen. Das ist sozusagen ihre interessant.
Die implizite Unterstellung hier wäre, dass Google ein Angebot bei Google News bevorzugt.
Ja, ich kann auch bei Google Plus, ehrlich gesagt, keine Werbung entdecken. Also, das ist ähm.
Ja, aber wenn du dann jetzt irgendwann auf den Link klickst, dann kommt irgendwann Werbung.
Wo vielleicht unter Umständen Essenz drauf ist, unter Umständen vielleicht.
Deswegen muss muss Google News sterben damit.
Ja
So ähm weitere äh Behauptungen hier, denen sich der V,
Z entgegenstellt sind, glaube ich, der Erwähnung nicht mehr wert und ähnlich. Ähm er ist ja auch ein bisschen, wie er hier die Argumentation, ja, aber okay, wir haben äh,
wir haben eine Gegenkampagne und wir verlinken die und ich denke, dass natürlich gerade im Presserahmen äh durchaus diese diese Gegendarstellung äh,
In Ordnung, also wichtig ist und auch zur Kenntnis genommen werden sollte und ähm die haben sie ja auch hier in diesem Fall selber verfasst, insofern, wenn sie für den Leser offensichtlich unsinnig,
erscheint, dann ähm ist das eben deren Problem, ne. Guck mal, ob deine Anzeige neben ist. Nee, ist leider nicht.
Anzeige, doch da ist eine Anzeige hier oben, mein Werbeblogger entfernt die nur, müssen wir mal gucken, wie ähm,
Oben rechts. Ach ja, du siehst sie. Das ist eine Anzeige von sich selber, vom VDZ. Die haben auf ihrer eigenen Seite Werbung von sich selber,
Mal gucken, ist die äh ja, also okay, komm, es glaube ich,
Also wir sehen, ich denke, dass das man.
Ja, also wir haben hier mit einer mit äh Monetarisierung von Facebook Präsenzen, da werben sie mit. Das ist auch lustig.
Ich gucke jetzt mal ganz kurz mir noch den Quelltext an. Also das äh ob das googlen.
Okay, lass uns da nicht so lange drauf äh festhängen. Also wir nehmen zur Kenntnis, äh der VDZ hat da eine andere Meinung, das ist ja in dem Sinne nichts Neues
und äh der, dein Netz, äh verteidige dein Netzkampagne von äh Google. Setzen sie hier ein im Blog-Style
äh über gefühlte fünf Bildschirmseiten verteilten grauen äh Text.
Und das wird wahrscheinlich alles ändern. Gut war's das?
Sie haben Google Plus-Button eingebunden da drunter. Also okay, äh ich denke, das war's. Äh was soll man dazu noch sagen, ne?
Genau, was soll man dazu auch noch sagen? Was äh müssen wir denn noch sagen? Können wir noch was zu sagen? Ich hätte ja vielleicht auch noch einen kleinen Hinweis.
Ha
Äh auch wenn das nicht unbedingt jetzt so direkt ein Netz,
Politisches Thema ist, fand ich das aber trotzdem mal das Aufgreifens äh würdig und zwar äh,
immer gute Nachrichten von den äh Piraten, wie ich das so sehe. In Berlin sind ja die Piraten ähm jetzt schon seit längerer Zeit,
der Leitung des äh Untersuchungsausschusses zum Thema Berliner Flughafen beschäftigt und Martin Delius ist dort der Vorsitzende und leitet das Ganze.
Und ja, die nehmen das dann auch sehr interessant auf,
wesentlich groß über das Pro und Contra dieses Flughafens reden. Da ist ja an anderer Stelle schon eine Menge gesagt worden, aber vor allem
find ich halt sehr interessant wie sie da herangehen. Und jetzt ist es so, dass hier wohl ein Entwickler an die Piraten herangetreten ist, der gesagt hat ich hab da so 'ne Software entwickelt, die ist auch auf, ich glaub die heißt irgendwie Big Project
Data oder sowas. Und äh die wurde jetzt äh herangenommen, um ein
Bairwatch genannte Webpräsenz zu bauen. Das ist quasi so ein
Dokumentenabwurfplatz, wo man eben alle möglichen Dokumente, die
bekannt geworden sind, veröffentlicht worden sind, einfach reinwerfen kann. Ähm
so in PDF-Form und äh ein Interface bietet eben selbige Aufzufinden, zu kommentieren und miteinander in Bezug zu setzen. Das äh lässt sich wohl auch anonym machen
so dass das quasi jetzt so ein Fundus ist für Journalisten und andere Leute, die sich eben an der Aufklärung dieser ganzen äh Sache,
teiligen wollen. Warum erwähne ich das? Ich erwähne das, weil das einfach eine interessante äh Umsetzung ist, die sich vielleicht auch für, also.
Ich habe jetzt keine Erfahrung gesammelt mit dieser Plattform. Das muss ich jetzt mal hier noch mit reinschieben, aber
Ich finde den Gedanken sehr interessant und man muss das mal beobachten welche Auswirkungen das hat weil das wird dich jetzt mal wieder so 'ne angewandte, ganz angewandte Nutzung des Netzes ist eben für den politischen Prozess,
Und äh in ähnlicher Hinsicht könnte so eine Plattform natürlich auch wertvoll sein für andere äh
Projekte, also gerade wenn's jetzt darum geht, ne, wenn wir uns jetzt erinnern hier so Acta, keiner weiß was ganz genau hier und da ist mal ein Dokument aufgetaucht et cetera PP,
genauso könnte man also dafür äh ein Acta-Watch äh eröffnen mit einer entsprechenden Software. Gut Akte ist jetzt äh raus, aber äh Leistungsschutzrecht ist sicherlich genauso ein dankbares äh Thema
oder eben was auch immer äh The Next Pixing ist, wo es einfach darum geht, mal wirklich auch ähm zu sammeln, also Berichte zu sammeln, Presseberichte zu sammeln, Originaldokumente zu sammeln und eben miteinander in Bezug zu stellen
um eben da auch einfach eine belegbare Recherche äh machen zu können. Sowohl als Plattform für Journalisten, als eben auch als Plattform für Aktivisten.
Spannend ist äh, dass sie also, was man, wenn du nochmal auf die Startseite gehst, wenn ein Dokument, was dort hochgeladen wird, wird automatisch auch OCR erfasst,
Man muss ja davon ausgehen, dass vieles davon dann PDFs sind oder vielleicht auch nur Scans von von gedruckten Dokumenten. Das heißt, die bauen sofort so eine Art äh,
Index dann auch der Inhalte dieser Dokumente ähm erlauben dann das Erstellen von Ereignissen
die dann im Zweifelsfall äh quasi in einer Abfolge gebracht werden können, sodass sich da automatisch eine ein sehr umfangreiche Zeitlinie der Ereignisse
ergibt und ermöglichen, dass herstellen zwischen diesen Beziehungen
von Dokumenten, wo jetzt zum Beispiel so was ist, äh hier mal randomly herausgegriffen. Der erste Satz dieses Vermerks widerspricht dem Inhalt des Vermerks in einem anderen Dokument äh von äh.
Einmal ein Datum.
Von einem anderen Datum, ja? Ähm und das sind also Dinge, die diese Dokumentenbeziehung, die dann
der da rumrecherchiert, dem was auffällt, dort quasi unterbringen kannst, 'n sehr spannende Sache.
Genau, also da,
Wollte ich nur mal drauf äh hinweisen, dass ihr da vielleicht mal so ein bisschen äh klickt und euch mal so ein bisschen Gedanken äh macht, also jetzt gerade mal so hier an die Aktivisten
Front gewendet ob sowas nicht vielleicht etwas sein könnte mit dem man mal etwas herumspielen will.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Sehr aufgeräumt auch aus.
Sieht auch gut aus, ja. Das hat äh ich glaube, der Hauptentwickler war der Holger D siebenundsiebzig. Heißt er.
Auf Twitter oder was?
Genau so heißt der auch auf auf Twitter und auf Gitter. Daher.
Django Projekt im Übrigen und.
Genau, vielleicht können wir dazu auch noch ein bisschen ähm mehr recherchieren in einer der folgenden Sendungen.
Wunderbar.
Ne? Gut, das war's.
Jetzt haben wir hier äh zwei Sendungen schnelle Folge gemacht. Es lag im Wesentlichen da dran, dass es A terminlich alles ein bisschen aneinandergerutscht ist und ich auch die andere erst spät veröffentlichen konnte.
Ja, zu viel Zeit lassen wir uns dann mit der Zweiundfünfzig nicht. Ich äh hoffe, ihr fühlt euch alle wieder ausreichend informiert.
Ja
Hinweise zu großen Verschiebungen im Raum Zeitkantine. Gerne an uns. Zum Beispiel auf Twitter, ME Unterstrich Netzpolitik, kann man auch mal drauf hinweisen.
Oder über die Sonstigen Bekannten, geheimen Kanäle.
Die Bekannten gaben keine. Ich finde, wir hätten uns noch mehr über die Netzneutralitätsachen mit Google aufregen müssen. Ja, äh es gab ja äh teilweise den Hörerhinweis, dass wir uns nicht mehr ausreichend aufregen. Mhm.
Plötzlich. Es gibt doch den es gibt auch, gibt auch das Gegenteil, die.
Ciao.
Du böse. Okay, das war's. Tschüss.